it's the stuff of nightmares the plane
door flung open in Flight as the Asiana
Airlines jet approached the South Korean
city of Daegu
passengers holding on against the force
of the wind luckily wearing seat belts
as the plane was minutes from Landing
it likely saved their lives when a man
opened the emergency door as the jet was
descending
still the pilots managed to land safely
and the man was arrested on board his
motivation unclear but his actions
injuring 12 people most suffering
breathing difficulties
it's an outcome that could have been so
much worse nine people died in 1989 when
the cargo door of this 747 blew off on
route to New Zealand twenty thousand
feet above the Pacific
the South Korean plane was just 700 feet
above ground when the incident happened
which meant the passengers could breathe
but it also meant the emergency door
could be opened whereas on higher
altitudes the cabin pressure seals its
shot but whether the airline could have
done anything to prevent this will now
form part of the investigation into what
was a very close call Milena
vaselinovich Sky News